we both died in video games it could be
running out of air in Sonic the Hedgehog
are falling off building in GTA are even
battling a honey badger in Far Cry we've
all passed away digitally but as video
games become increasingly cinematic and
interactive the way a character dies has
become an opportunity to strike fear in
the hearts of gamers today we count down
eight horrific ways to die in video
games we want potential spoilers for the
following and this isn't one for the
squeamish Lara Croft is a born survivor
but I doubt anyone can complete her
latest adventures without sharing this
fate I thought being impaled through the
brain would kill her instantly but Lara
refuses to give up and uses her last few
seconds to free herself but to no avail
kratos from the God of War series has
murdered his way through thousands upon
thousands of enemies but the beheading
of Helios in God of War II has given me
nightmares using his bare hands Kratos
rips off the head of Helios to harness
the power of the Sun
we're shooting people joel has been that
way for a long time we are survivors our
chance it is over Tess
the last of us in our eyes the greatest
game of last generation so when it
resurfaced on ps4 we couldn't help but
jump straight back into Joel Jules to
save Ellie all was going well until we
met warn enemy type called the blotter
who quickly demonstrated another
gruesome way to die
Mortal Kombat 10 could easily fill this
list all on its own so choosing a single
entry proved difficult in the end we
decided upon Johnny cages recreation of
Jack Nicholson in the shining
here's Johnny
little girl don't lie to me tell me
where
you let your guard down with something
simple people died for all of it she'll
shaded child-friendly graphics The
Walking Dead video game had moment which
crushed the audience for example when
Carver finally meets his demise through
the heavy hand of Kenny the player
decides if Clementine an 8 year old girl
should watch or not by having her stand
there makes its evil characters end
feels so much worse
let's go
until dawn an interactive horror game
which has you running for your life and
fearing every noise luckily for Josh he
didn't have to wait too long he became
the victim of this golem Eska diamond
outlast is the penultimate horrific
death on our list this game is so scary
I didn't actually finish playing it and
had to get a friend in to record the
footage the game has you investigating
an asylum looking for a journalistic
scoop which will further your career so
off you go with your trusty night-vision
video camera but it soon becomes
apparent the survival will be a little
tricky the whistleblower DLC introduces
us to any Gluskin who mutilate or the
men to make them look like his ideal
woman
including genital and chest mutilation
all in an attempt to create a bride for
himself he is referred to as the groom
we've done it we've reached the top of
the list which comes from dead space too
although the game isn't as terrifying as
the original it did offer new and
ridiculous ways to play in this section
the player is required to lay down in
the diagnostic machine which recovers
information from a part of the brain
only accessible through the ocular
cavity if all goes well the scene is
disturbing but if you get it wrong this
scene is brutally terrifying so they
were our picks for the most gruesome and
horrific ways to die in video games did
we miss any let us know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed wasting time
with us please subscribe for more see
you soon